So the information about
the Hufting bound gives us a way of
thinking about how many samples we need
to accurately learn the value of an arm.
So we're going to have to
actually pick a number for that.
How many samples we're going to take of
each arm to guide us in that decision.
It's going to be helpful to think about
how we're going to combine information
across the arms.
So this is going to be a strategy
that will ultimately work,
though we don't have all the details
filled in yet, and it goes like this.
What we're going to do is, we're
going to take c samples of each arm for
some value c.
>> That's what I was going to do.
>> The c is going to be some function of
epsilon delta k, that sort of thing, but
it's going to be some number, and
it's going to be a number that,
well, we're going to see.
It's going to be some number that
guarantees that we're some amount
close with some certainty.
And then after that point,
we're going to choose the arm that has
the highest estimate, the best estimate.
>> All right.
>> Ultimately, we want our final
decision here to be epsilon
close to the optimal decision
with probability 1 minus delta.
So I claim that to do that,
for this to work,
we need to learn each arm individually
to an accuracy of epsilon over
2 with a certainly of
1 minus delta over k.